thank you very much for being on the
program well we just heard from
matt hancock what's your reaction to his
interview
well i'm angry to be honest i've been
watching
like everybody else the case rates
rising for several weeks
and seen every day this week we've
raised with the government
the fact that this new strain of the
virus surely means that christmas plans
have to be
revised and yet every day that concern
has been
dismissed ridiculed by the prime
minister in the house commons on
wednesday
only to find yesterday that people have
made plans over the last week that now
lie in tatters um with very little time
to sort that out before christmas and
that the virus has been allowed to
spread
over and over again we've seen the same
pattern a prime minister who rejects the
evidence
who ridicules and mocks people who raise
concerns who dithers and delays and then
ends up having to change his mind at the
11th hour this is how a country
that has pioneering scientists and a
healthcare system that is the envy of
the world
ends up with the worst number of deaths
in europe
and the worst recession of any major
economy we just cannot continue like
this
because what matt hancock and you know
the government would argue is that
they couldn't have predicted the new
variant they only got the
evidence uh on friday of
transmissibility
um i understand you know the the
difficulties that many have and that
anger may feel towards the way this
policy has been
communicated building up people's hopes
taking them away again
but is the policy itself the right thing
to do something that labor supports
it's absolutely the right thing to do to
bring in tougher restrictions
around christmas and i think most of the
country could see for several weeks that
this is where
it was going we didn't know about the
new strain of the varys a few weeks ago
but we did know that case rates were
rising
at an alarming rate in some parts of the
country in particular in london in the
south east
and matt hancock came to the house of
commons on monday to report that there
was this new strain of the virus which
he said at the time was particularly
virulent
the government did know that this was an
emerging problem and yet two days later
the prime minister
went to the house of commons mocked and
ridiculed concerns that were raised
about it
and said that those who were concerned
about it like kirsten the labour leader
were seeking to criminalize people and
to cancel christmas the trouble with all
of this is that it's the government that
is always
too slow to act too slow to act on the
evidence that is
in front of them in plain sight and
we've seen this over and over again
over the last 12 months and that is why
we're in
this situation right now going into the
new year
i didn't hear anything from matt hancock
that suggested that the government is
really going to get a grip on this we'll
have schools returning
in the first week or so of the new year
they've really got to start getting mass
testing rolled out in schools get a grip
on test trace and isolate
and make sure that they execute the
vaccination plan
properly so that we can get that rolled
out across the country
on schools specifically should the
government be be considering closing
schools
in tier 4 areas where the virus is
increasing
i think schools should be the last thing
to close and the first thing to open
we've said that all year and the reason
for that is because
we've seen what is happening to children
when they have prolonged periods of
absence
from school we'll be living with the
consequences of this for generations to
come
if we don't i think that's right so i
understand you think it should be
the last thing the last resort but is
that something that should be considered
as a last resort if infections are still
rising
well i think we should start focusing on
the first resort the first resort is
about getting mass testing
into schools and so far the government
has for a month has been
uh mucking about not getting that those
plans in place
we've had endless questions and debates
about that in the house of commons
and only on friday we had teachers uh
sent instructions about what they were
supposed to do over the school
holidays so after the one of the most
stressful years that i think any of them
can remember they're now working flat
out over the school holidays to try and
put new plans
in place for january we just can't
continue like this the government has
got to get mass testing into schools
they should try and keep schools open it
just cannot countenance the idea
that for some children they'll have what
is effectively almost a year
of missed education they will live with
those consequences for a long time to
come and the most disadvantaged
children will be the ones who suffer the
most we
just shouldn't be debating whether we
should be closing schools we should be
debating how we safely keep them open
the announcement yesterday of course
affected well everybody
in the country and millions of people
having their christmas plans
ruined many of us uh living under these
tier four restrictions for
well after hearing from matt hancock
potentially some months to come
do you think parliament needs to be
recalled so mps can vote on it
well there will be a vote as as matt
hancock said to you earlier there'll be
a vote at some point before
the 1st of february and i think the most
important thing right now
is just that there is clarity about the
new rules
and that we make sure that people
understand those and can follow them
safely
i don't think it'd be wise for mps to be
travelling across the country
into london in the south east which is
now subject to tier four
restrictions in order to debate
something that the government has the
power to do that they've said very
clearly
must be done in the last 24 hours we
finally got clarity we now need
to focus on making sure that people have
the support that they need to follow the
rules and to
to get to grips with what has been a
really chaotic
um set of announcements over the last 24
hours now that we've got clarity i think
that should absolutely be the priority
um i'm interested as well in how
strictly you think the rules
should be enforced um should the police
be able to hand out fines to people who
break the rules over christmas
if you knew your neighbor was breaking
the rules would you call the police
what's the position well here in the
north of england we've been
living under quite serious restrictions
since the summer and the police here
have largely
i think got it right in very difficult
circumstances they've taken a fairly
light
touch approach they haven't wanted to
bust in on
children's birthday parties and family
dinners but they have been very visible
they have been reminding people
about how serious this is when they need
to take action they do
but in general they're trusting people
they're asking people they're appealing
to people
to look out for one another and keep
each other safe and i think most of the
country is absolutely
trying to do that where we run into
problems is not so much
about enforcement or lack of enforcement
the problem is when people are confused
about what the rules are and that's why
it is so serious that the prime minister
on wednesday
was saying in the house of commons that
christmas would absolutely go ahead as
planned that there was
no chance at all it would be inhumane he
said to cancel
christmas and then just a few a few days
later
he's saying something different we just
cannot have a prime minister continuing
to make promises that he knows
he cannot keep we've seen this all year
we just need a
far better communication from this
government far more honesty
and matt hancock told me that he had
called his mum to say that you know
christmas was off
um how are you planning on spending
christmas
yeah i i called my mum as well actually
and keir had a
phone call with the prime minister
yesterday uh ahead of the announcement
and one of the first things i did was to
call my mum
uh just to to talk about christmas we
were always planning a very small
quiet family christmas we're in a
support bubble with my mum
and so we're planning to continue that
but it is
hard because i do have family members
who are going to be spending christmas
alone this year that's not something any
of us really wanted to see but we're
just trying to do what i think everybody
else is trying to do which is to say
you know this is just this has been one
hell of a year
and we've just got to chalk it up to
2020 this is what it's been like
and hopefully this time next year we'll
be in a far far better position if we
all stay safe and follow the rules and
look after each other
it does feel like quite a universal
reaction first thing you do is you want
to get on the phone to your mum to try
and work out what on earth
her to do in the situation that we're
all in
of course you know top of everyone's
mind this morning is the coverage
restrictions what it means for them and
their families but
it's right to touch on brexit as well
because we just got 11 days to the end
of the transition
if there is a deal is labour minded to
back it
we'd be minded to back it but we don't
know what it what would be in it
and we've had over the last few months
we've had a prime minister that has
broken promises over and over again that
has tried to use the
good friday agreement as a bargaining
chip in negotiations
and has threatened to tear up
international law
um in order to get his deal through so
we want to see that deal
first we don't trust that the prime
minister will come back with a deal
that's
in the national interest but we've
always said that we think that a deal
is absolutely essential no deal would be
a disaster for many businesses and
people across this country so
we would be minded to support it but we
need to see what's in it what we hope
most of all is that the government will
get its act together in these last 11
days and make sure that there is a deal
and that people aren't waking up on the
1st of january in the middle of a global
pandemic
with all of the chaos that a no deal
brexit would bring
it's interesting isn't it you know you
say that labour's always been of the
view that you'd like to see a deal
at the same time though you know if i
kind of rewind to the not too distant
past
you know you've always been someone
who's talked about the importance of
honoring
the result of the referendum you
seriously considered backing theresa
may's deal
at a time when keith starman was
actually arguing for a second referendum
is he finally catching up with you
i think it's more a question of of the
options that we've got in front of us
and confronting those
realities the truth is that the question
was fundamentally settled
last december at the general election
when the prime minister won
a majority an 80-seat majority with the
promise to get brexit done
the the option of a second referendum is
gone we we have left the european union
we left in january
so the option is do we have a deal or do
we not have a deal do we continue to
trade do our businesses continue to
thrive
can we continue to do well as a country
or are we going to allow the government
to crash us out of the eu without a deal
and hold the country back
and that you know on that i think the
labour party is completely united we
have got to
go forwards we've got to stop the
disunity and the division that has held
the country back over recent years and
we've got to get a good deal
and kira and i are absolutely of one
mind about that okay
lisa nundy thank you very much indeed
for being on the program thank you